meant  i'd be like one i know they're pretty  but  be careful son  no i want something specific uh wear a  condom  [Music]  okay don't get the wrong [ __ ] pregnant  i swear to god you come home pregnant  i'm not helping you  um  don't believe her she's on birth control  i don't care how nice she is you never  know  that's true um  that goes back to it is it her  responsibility to his responsibility  i would say it's mostly hers because  again no woman can carry a child that  she does not take to term  but don't give her that power son don't  don't give her that power um two  i would say  look for a girl that has the same values  as you  that's really important  um three  pay attention to how attention seeking  she is  especially and pay attention to